let's circle back
to bitcoin now because i said i i saw
you and your wife kim you interviewed
on your radio show um raul paul is that
how you say his name
and he was the one that sort of said
yeah let's get going on this bitcoin
thing and sort of convince you to go
over to hop
the hump and obviously elon musk made
the 1.5 billion
investment into bitcoin this past week
what is it about bitcoin that is so uh
intoxicating or that that makes you such
a believer
now well it's not really bitcoin is it's
blockchain
okay and it's a contract and
you know when people when guys like you
know peter chess my friend
and he and max kaiser go back and forth
i don't know why they that's to me it's
like a food fight
you know you know max kaiser says peter
schiff is stupid and
kaiser says i mean and schiff says
kaiser is stupid
i i always support what yogi berra the
great new york yankees catcher said
yeah when you come to a fork in the road
take it
so it's you know it's i'm glad i took
bitcoin
when it was like nine thousand dollars
look at it now almost at 45.
but i'm not buying anymore you're not
what
and i'm not buying anymore and i i was
buying gold at 300
i'm not buying anymore why are you no
longer buying bitcoin do you not think
it can go from 45 to 100 or to 500
500 000 for you know i'm not a
speculator
that's true okay
speak about being a i assume when you
buy silver you you bought and hold
silver all this time you're not
selling it is that right no i never sell
so you buy and hold like you know these
idiots flip real estate
you get a good property i keep it
forever
and then i'm going to put all i'm going
to put my millions and millions and
millions of dollars
into a thing called a crt a charitable
remainder trust
and i'm going to pass it into perpetuity
as charity
never going to spend that money but it's
going to be used as charity i'll give it
back
but most people are flipping you know
flipping houses
that's really stupid because you get
nail volt capital gains tax
you flip bitcoin you got capital gains i
i just don't like paying taxes
if you ever ever listen to lenin lenin
said two things okay that was crucial
he says he wanted to watch capitalism
you about you want to kill capitalism
you botched the currency and that's what
nixon did in 781
and it says if you want to kill
capitalism tax
tax tax and that's what biden's doing
right now tax taxes
so that's why what real financial
education
that sign back here says cash flow i'm a
cash flow fanatic
i want to make sure the cash is flowing
in and none is flowing to the government
that's why trump and i don't pay taxes
legally we're real estate guys
let's talk about real estate for a
second um hang on
yes sir i don't think anybody
understands the power of
debt and you know these idiots out there
are telling you get out of debt
well debt is money that's what happened
in 781
when nixon took the dollar off the gold
standard so in 2008
you were probably on wall street at the
time or something
i thought i died and went to heaven they
dropped interest rates to all-time lows
and the best real estate floated to the
surface on the market
so i borrowed 300 million dollars and
bought real estate
with debt now the average person can't
do that
that's why this board game cash flow so
you can understand the way
capitalists think i don't like the stock
market
i would have made billions in the stock
market except that you know i do have to
sleep at night
that's the reason fair enough thank you
for watching this short clip if you want
to see the full
episode check it out right here and if
you have not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here
[Music]
you